now
if if we use the model that ivy leagues
use
would the ivy leagues call the nba races
for not being diverse enough
no because the ivy leagues have a narrow
definition of racism in order for it to
be racist it has to be
power plus privilege and so they define
power as
white power so if there's too many
whites it's racist
but if they're too many black americans
it's fine why is that i'm curious
because they believe that whites are the
privileged race
in america they're the powerful race
so it's only racist if it's the powerful
who are oppressing
the powerless according to who they are
the privileged race who
according to critical race theorists
according to
you know critical race theory started at
harvard law school in the sixth in the
70s
and 90s yeah can you tell us about the
history that and obviously we we've
we've had the
others on that i've spoken about that
word this is kind of a
uh they're indoctrinating also in the
military i had the former
space force commander who got fired from
his position for
talking about these things but elaborate
a little bit more when you say you know
crt started in the 70s with harvard
well in the 70s derrick bell who's a
harvard law professor was the first
black professor at harvard
he created a department called critical
legal studies the purpose of critical
legal studies was to investigate
the way that that the the
the way that race still plays a part in
so-called colorblind law is what he
called it so he's trying to sort of
to show that our laws are still racist
that that's what he was that's what he
was trying to do and then he had a bunch
of students who came in
um kimberly crenshaw mary matsuda
roberto unger they they developed
a a separate theory under him called
critical race theory
which is which basically asserts that
society in america
has a privilege has privileged races and
oppressed races
and our loss today still privileged the
privileged races
so you don't you don't think that some
of the laws in the 60s
were a bit racist no no the laws in the
60s were def okay
we're definitely racist but here's what
a critical legal studies person
please would say he would say
you would say the civil rights for
example the civil rights act of 1965
says the state will not discriminate on
the basis of race ethnicity color skin
national origin anything like that a
critical
legal studies person would look at that
law and he would say
that law is still racist because
that law who because that what that law
does
is um it's it's it's
it's saying that even even even
even though it says that the state
should not discriminate
um what it's doing is it's refining the
current structure of america where
whites are still at the top and blacks
are still at the bottom so
e that law is is a kind of it's a new
base it's a neutral law but it's not
really a neutral law because it's still
refining the current power structure
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye